One of the oldest and most influential megacorporations
in the world of Cyberpunk is Arasaka.
It has played a pivotal part in some of the
franchises most important stories and is set
to be a major player in Cyberpunk 2077.
In many ways it's looking like Arasaka's role
in the game is set to be the culmination of
characters and plotlines the pen and paper
game has been building for decades.
So before we see it play out in the video
game, you need to know the history of Arasaka,
who its major players are, and how the simple
manufacturing company became a trojan horse
for world domination.
The now monolithic Arasaka started out as
a simple Japanese manufacturing company.
It was founded around the turn of the twentieth
century by Sasai Arasaka, a clever businessman
with a talent for predicting the direction
the world was going.
He saw World War 2 on the horizon and positioned
his company as a major military manufacturer
for Japan, bringing him a lot of success.
Sasai also had the foresight to see that Japan
would lose, so Arasaka began distributing
its vast wealth to overseas accounts, sparing
itself from the ruin of the Japanese economy
following the country's surrender.
In the years following the war, Arasaka would
slowly trickle those funds back in, keeping
the company on top as a vital part of Japan.
That’s how Arasaka got its start but the
history of the modern day Arasaka begins with
Sasai’s son, Saburo.
Saburo Arasaka was a renowned pilot during
WW2.
He was fiercely nationalistic, strongly believing
that Japan should take its rightful place
as leader of the world.
Japan’s surrender at the end of World War
2 was a huge blow for Saburo, who contemplated suicide,
but like his father he had the vision
and foresight to think ahead.
Saburo saw the global economic path the world
was taking and knew that while Japan had failed
militarily, it could succeed commercially.
Thanks to his father’s actions, Arasaka
continued to thrive and accrue a massive fortune
after the war.
So Saubro prepared and waited until his Father’s
death in 1960 when he assumed control of Arasaka.
It was then time for Saubro to start his long
game.
His end goal?
To bring back Japan to imperial glory and
become a political and economic superpower
that controlled the world.
Saburo's first step was to create and expand
the Arasaka Bank.
The bank acted as the reliable backbone of
the company, always providing good income
thanks to smart business decisions on Saburo’s
end.
This allowed Arasaka the freedom to invest
in other ventures such as the Arasaka Security
Division, which provided the highest standards
of electronic security as well as physical
manpower like armed guards.
By the 1990’s Arasaka Security was the most
powerful and respected security company in
the world, with thousands of businesses using
their services.
And then the collapse happened.
Ever the forward-thinker, Saubro saw the economic
crash coming and made preparations as well
as a few manipulations in order to profit
from the destruction of modern society.
Arasaka came out of the collapse as one of
the largest corporations in the world, and
it was time for Saubro’s masterplan to take
shape.
Arasaka Security would create one of the first
corporate armies.
Saburo would go on a spree, buying out valuable
businesses with Arasaka Bank in one hand,
and eviscerating the competition with his
personal army with the other.
By 2020 the mantle of CEO passed to Saburo’s
eldest son, Kei Arasaka.
But in many ways Kei was just a figurehead
and the true power and decision making still
lay with the 101 year old Saburo.
His mind was still as sharp as ever and his
goal of complete world domination was ever
present.
The only thing keeping him from achieving
it was alliances made by other corporations
in the interest of keeping Arasaka in check.
One such corporation was Militech, an American
arms manufacturer and military contractor.
Militech was Arasaka’s biggest competitor
and this rivalry would end up being the source
of Arasaka’s first major defeat.
What would later be known as the Fourth Corporate
War started in 2021 as a simple rivalry between
two CINO and OTEC, which were fighting over
the assets of the recently bankrupt IHAG.
Looking to gain the upper hand, both turned
to the backing of large megacorps for military
resources.
OTEC went with Militech, and CINO went with
Arasaka.
The two mega corps had been at each other's
throats for years and this was the perfect
excuse they had been looking for to begin
a proxy war where they could battle it out.
And like many proxy wars it stopped being
about a dispute over a bankrupt company's
assets.
In fact by 2022 CINO and OTEC had settled
their little war, but Arasaka and Militech
were just getting started and tensions quickly
escalated into a very real war.
Many organizations and countries around the
globe were dragged into their conflict, including
the United States and Japan, both of whose
economies heavily relied on Militech and Arasaka
respectively.
Things were spiraling out of control quickly
as this corporate rivalry was setting the
world on fire.
Eventually Arasaka began losing ground in
the United States with its final major hold
out being Night City, home of its American
headquarters.
This all led to one of the most important
moments in the world of Cyberpunk.
Militech sent several strike teams of mercenaries
to infiltrate Arasaka Tower.
One of which was led by the legendary Johnny
Silverhand.
You can learn more about why Johnny was involved
in our video on him.
There's a lot that happened in Araska Tower
that day, enough to do a whole video on it
alone, but the most important thing is how
it ended.
A thermonuclear device was detonated, resulting
in the destruction of Central Night City and
the deaths of over half a million people in
what would be referred to as the Night City
Holocaust.
The blame was placed on Arasaka and US President
Elizabeth Kress used the event to nationalize
Militech and expel Arasaka from the United
States.
Small conflicts continued for two more years
but at this point Arasaka had lost.
CEO Kei Arasaka, eldest son of Saburo, committed
suicide in 2025, offically bringing the Forth
Corporate War to an end.
The fallout of the war severely damaged Arasaka.
All its overseas assets had been seized by
different governments, and it was kicked out
of pretty much everywhere.
The Japanese government, which had long butted
heads with Arasaka, was terrified of a potential
retaliation from other nations, despite not
being directly involved.
But the government still needed Arasaka due
to its massive influence on the Japanese economy.
So the government nationalized all of Arasaka’s
assets and Arasaka became a Japan-only company
for the next decade.
With the loss of its CEO and power, an internal
power struggle took place within Arasaka.
There are three major players.
The first was the Kiji, led by Hanako Arasaka,
the youngest daughter of Saburo.
Hanako is an intelligent and kind hearted
woman who wanted to live an independent life
rather than be a pawn in her father's corporate
game, which is perhaps why she led a faction
to grab the power for herself.
Next there’s the Hato faction, led by Michiko
Arasaka, the youngest daughter of the late
Kei.
She is a US citizen and had the backing of
the US Government, which wanted to take control
of Arasaka.
The final group is the outside rebel faction
Taka, led by Yorinobu Arasaka, another of
Soburo’s children.
Yorinobu is by far the most interesting of
the three.
When his father told him of the true purpose
of the Arasaka Corporation, Yorinobu left
his family in disgust.
He went on to become a famous Rockerboy, the
Johnny Silverhand of Japan; moreso in the
rebellious spirit as he was not an actual
musician.
He started the Steel Dragons (Kotetsu no Ryu),
a gang he used to attack Arasaka from the
shadows.
Yorinobu was even involved in the events leading
up to the Nuclear detonation of Arasaka Tower.
Unfortunately there’s not much information
on the details of this decade long family
rivalry.
However, the conflict was eventually solved
and Arasaka reunited under one banner again.
Arasaka spent much of the next several decades
rebuilding power and regaining a foothold
outside of Japan.
A return to America was tricky following its
expulsion in 2023, but an opportunity presented
itself for Arasaka to worm its way back in.
The New United States had what was known as
the Unification War in 2069, an attempt by
the government to regain control of a series
of free states that had seceded from the nation.
Night City had long been warry of the US after
it basically abandoned the city following
the Night City Holocaust.
The City avoided involvement in the war until
the federal invasion of Coronado Bay gave
them no choice but to act.
City Councilman Lucius Rhyne turned to Arasaka
for help.
This was the opportunity Arasaka was looking
for and it showed up days later with a supercarrier
causing a swift retreat of the NUSA.
The sudden involvement of Arasaka drummed
up fears of another 4th Corporate War level
crisis, and as such the New United States
backed down and signed a treaty of unification,
ending the short lived war.
Night City was now an independent city-state
and by the present day of 2077, Arasaka was
once again in control of the city.
Which brings us to the upcoming game in which
Arasaka plays a pretty major role.
If you pick the Corpo Life Path option, main
character V will start as an employee for
Arasaka's counterintelligence division and
you’ll get to see the ruthless Arasaka corporate
lifestyle for yourself.
The company is also involved in the game’s
main plot, which involves stealing an ancient
prototype chip from Arasaka.
Expect an appearance from Saburo Arasaka himself,
who is still CEO of the company at the ripe
old age of 158.
How can he possibly still be alive you ask?
We’ll let's just say Saburo had plans long
ago to download his personality into an AI
when he died.
The very existence of this piece of tech has
been at the heart of many of Cyberpunk’s
most important stories and will be an important
part of the game.
Yorinobu will also play a role in the story.
He has, for unknown reasons, returned to the
fold of his father’s empire.
But knowing him, he has his own plans and
motivations.
The events of Cyberpunk 2077 might end up
being another major chapter in the history
of Arasaka.
We covered a lot of information today and
there are plenty of details left for further
exploration.
In fact, next week Jake will be diving deeper
into the Fourth Corporate War so make sure
to come back for that.
As always let us know if there’s a particular
subject in the world of Cyberpunk you want
to know more about, and thanks for watching.